diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit brk
modell der krieger genuss seit 1922
[Musik]
für die jüngeren ist sie auf jeden fall
die kanzlerin die immer da war also die
ewige kanzlerin merkel war immer da muti
war immer da war ja schon fast eine
präsidentin kanzlerin die oberhalb der
parteien oberhalb der innenpolitischen
kämpfe schwebte über jahre
in sich ruhend ist sie eigentlich immer
ein gewisser weise aber ihre ihre
position die ausstellung ist doch sehr
gebröckelt
im laufe der letzten zwei jahre oder der
letzten drei vier jahre
von daher ja es war ein bisschen merkel
dämmung
heiko sakurai zeigt mir eines seiner
bücher
das vor zehn jahren erschien ist ein
bestseller in deutschland miss germany
aber hier ist sie noch wichtig in
siegerpose
das hat sich schon verändert das hat
sich verändert
zumal jetzt in der letzten zeit ja also
die und strengte herrscherin und die
ungefährdete machtposition dass es
vergangenheit als korrespondent habe ich
über verschiedene regierungschef
staatsoberhäupter präsidenten berichtet
diese beobachtet und begleitet merkel
ist besonders bedacht regieren
pragmatisch und ziemlich frei von
eitelkeit auch deshalb anders als die
meisten anderen
sie hat mich beeindruckt und nicht
selten auch verblüfft mit entscheidungen
die von ihr kaum jemand erwartet hat
merkel hat deutschland geprägt und in
europa und in der welt neu positioniert
und sie hat mit ihren entscheidungen das
land die gesellschaft und die politik
verändert dieser film ist eine reise
durch deutschland an orte um zu menschen
die nicht in den letzten jahren schon
einmal begegnet bin und deren leben
anders geworden ist in merkels nun fast
15-jähriger kanzlerschaft meine reise
beginnt im osten in eisenach wo 1685
johann sebastian bach geboren wurde
über der stadt thront die wartburg die
kanzlerin war ein jahr alt als in
eisenach der erste band burg in
produktion ging das vorzeige auto des
ddr-regimes das autowerk und die ddr
gibt es nicht mehr
seit 1991 seit deutschland einheit ist
matthias klug war damals 14 jahre alt
wir fahren zusammen von eisenach nach
waltershausen durch den thüringer wald
ich staune die gegend und internationale
unternehmen sind daher sehen wir sind ja
bei dätwyler einem schweizer unternehmen
hier ist klug geschäftsleiter früher die
größte gummi fabrik der ddr sei 2012 in
schweizer hand
reduzieren sie abdichtungen für den
tunnelbau für bahn und metros auf dem
ganzen globus machen die ganze welt
dicht wir machen die welt nicht gewinnen
also wir beliefern so zeit australien
russland kanada usa südamerika
wir haben viele projekte in skandinavien
gerade das ist der der exportweltmeister
deutschland zwei tiefste
arbeitslosenquote in der eu seit merkel
kanzlerin ist hat sich die
arbeitslosenzahl von 10 auf unter fünf
prozent halbiert wirtschaftswunder
viele sagen dankeschön dass
arbeitsmarktreformen der agenda 2010
klug sagt auch dank märkte glauben sie
hatte merkel auch noch positiv mit
eingewirkt
für uns ist denke ich auch frau merkel
sehr gut weil durch unseren hohen
exportanteil und auch gerade durch
märkte die sich immer die wo ein
gewisser protektionismus sich jetzt
einstellt wenn wir zum beispiel
nordamerika usa reden haben wir doch
noch ein sehr gutes verhältnis und ein
offenes verhältnis und da arbeitet sie
gut dran
da denke ich sie arbeitet ganz gut range
nach getaner arbeit nimmt er mich mit in
die innenstadt von eisenach
der finanzchef des werks ein schweizer
und dessen frau sind auch dabei und sie
schwammen vom guten und immer besseren
leben hier denke dass auch diese
strukturprogramme die aufgelegt worden
einfach jetzt auch mal zu sehen sind
auch gezogen habe der schweizer hat auch
eine positive entwicklung auf so dass
ein wechsel steht wird aber gestellt und
zudem entsteht was ich alles gemacht hat
renault bereits entwickelt sich zum
positiven und lebensqualität
keine stadt in deutschland ohne
weihnachtsmarkt eine thüringer bratwurst
gibt es für 2 euro
deutschland ist günstiger als die
schweiz aber auch die löhne sind tiefer
deutlich tiefer 2000 euro netto im
schnitt bei dätwyler das ist so wenn man
sagen mit der schweiz mal 120 euro
relativ die für löhne steigende
exportzahlen und geringe
arbeitslosigkeit in eisenach ist die
welt in ordnung also ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen sie jetzt im nachhinein
dieser merkel ehre er eigentlich als
sehr positiv also auch für uns mit mit
einer teilweise gewissen weit sich
teilweise auch vielleicht wird ein paar
kritischen schritten wenn man das jetzt
mit der zuwanderung unkontrolliert
bisschen betrachtet aber können sie
wieder denke ich schon dass sie im sinne
von europa und im sinne von weitsicht
gehandelt hat
prost auf eine gute zeit und auf die
kanzlerin im jahr 15 ihrer kanzlerschaft
reden sie gut wie bei angela merkel
jene welche teil sind des deutschen
wirtschaftswunders
wirtschaftswunder exportweltmeister das
ist nicht überall in deutschland für
reportagen war ich öfter in berlins
vorständen hellersdorf marzahn fernab
vom rausch des aufschwungs und der
leichtigkeit des lebens hier ist
arbeitslosigkeit und hartz 4
in diesem teil von hellersdorf sind 80
prozent der bewohner
sozialhilfeempfänger
leicht versteckt in einer seitenstraße
regt die arche
drinnen kinder die nicht teilhaben an in
dax und exportrekord deutschlands hier
kommen sie zum spielen zum basteln und
zum mittagessen
2015 weil ich in einer der 26 arche
einrichtungen in deutschland berichtete
darüber dass 2,6 millionen kinder von
transferleistungen leben und auf hilfe
wie die arche angewiesen sind
fünf jahre später sind es doppelt so
viele
die schere hat sich weiter aufgerissen
in ganz deutschland reich ist reicher
geworden
4,6 millionen kinder leben heute in
familien die transferleistungen beziehen
die nes am geld fehlt für bildung für
freizeitaktivitäten für ein würdiges
leben
ich treffe einen der gründer der
hellersdorfer arche wieder hallo
aufgebracht darüber vergessen zu sein
von denen die unweit von hier im
bundestag und kanzleramt entscheiden und
regieren die politik versagt hier auf
ganzer linie und wir werden der politik
auch bewusst vor dass sie viel zu wenig
macht um die kinder zu schützen
kanzlerin merkel hat sich als eine sehr
humanitäre kanzlerin erwiesen in den
letzten jahren hat sie zu wenig für die
kinder gemacht
ja wir haben mir ja auch viele
flüchtlingskinder insofern darf ich die
kritik auch üben
die kanzlerin hat viele menschen hier
nach deutschland geholt und wie hat man
sich gekümmert um die eigenen kinder
kümmert man sich nicht wir haben mit der
politik gesprochen aber danach ist
funkstille
ich werfe auch der kanzlerin ganz
gezielt vor dass sie nichts dafür tut
oder nichts für die kinder tut die in
deutschland in vergessenheit geraten
sind und wir reden hier von 4,6
millionen kinder die auch die kanzlerin
vergessen hat aber sie sind eben keine
bilder
lea ist sieben von zeit ihres lebens
kommt sie dreimal die woche zum essen
mit ihrer mama jessica white ist
dreifache mutter alleinerziehend
arbeitslos
der jüngere der beiden söhne alex ist 12
er kommt heute auch zum essen
wegen eines solchen schadens kann
jessica nicht mehr als lackiererin
arbeiten sie ist hartz iv empfängerin
und dankbar dass es die arche gibt sie
erinnert sich an das erste mal als sie
hier
hier wird man liebevoll aufgenommen
ein schiff an weil man ja geht oder so
und wenn die betreuer so mitkriegen was
man eigentlich gute sachen macht die man
durch die asche einspart muss man auch
eine positive rückmeldung als sein baby
bassum frisch geboren
hellersdorf am tag danach frühen morgen
hier wohnen die laues adventszeit der
morgen erwacht und mit ihm die kinder
jessica erhält rund 1300 euro für sich
und die kinder damit müssen sie im monat
auskommen
alex träumt von einem besseren leben
wer kann's kaum erwarten das nächste
türchen im adventskalender zu öffnen
[Musik]
es sind die kleinen dinge über die man
sich freut bei den laues und dann alltag
in großen verabschieden die kleine in
die schule bringen
jessica hat eine umschulung gemacht zur
kauffrau jedes jobangebot dass sie
seither erhalten hat würde weniger
einbringen als 1300 euro
willkommen im niedriglohnland
deutschland
solange ich einen hartz-iv-bescheid habe
und sämtliche hilfen in anspruch nehmen
kann habe ich mehr als wenn ich vollzeit
arbeiten gehen oder und das ist es ist
extrem also ich finde auch dass man über
diesen weg nicht die leute ran kriegt
dass die wirklich was tun
[Musik]
hartz4 heißt verzicht in einem land in
dem es alles gibt
hast du im monat fürs einkaufen also ich
habe mir im budget von pro woche 50 euro
gegeben wenn man letzte woche sehr
sparsam deswegen haben die kinder sich
zum beispiel heute auch hawaii toast
gewünscht es drinnen normalerweise gibt
es brot zum abendrot weil es halt
günstiger ist aber wenn man davor die
woche sparsam waren habe ich auch mal
ein paar extras um den kinder eine
kleine freude zu machen
nachmittags treffe ich alex vor der
schule wo er täglich für seinen reporter
traum lernt und von sich aus anfängt mit
mir über hartz4 zu sprechen
anders als die anderen
man hat nicht das was sie hier sie
können sich zum beispiel
mögliche sachen leisten sie töten jedes
jahr und wir müssen aufpassen und das
leben und man für dich oder du nicht
aber ich kann damit leben
also ich find das jetzt zwar ist es
nicht schön wenn man kann nicht mitreden
und hält nicht nur die dinger aber damit
geben kann
ich treffe noch einmal jessica wir reden
über die schere die sich weiter öffnet
in deutschlands gesellschaft und über
angela merkel ja ist wichtig dass im
ausland gut ankommt
ja natürlich aber warum die von merkel
nicht vertreten weil die frau merkel und
die politik allgemein hat wirklich
nichts mehr für den kleinen mann tot die
thuner ist für die konzerne aber für den
kleinen mann für den kleinen
arbeitnehmer durch mir sagte das ist
nicht mehr gerecht und ich finde die
politik war gefragt und sie ist immer
noch gefragt dass die dafür sorgen dass
das was oben verdient wird auch beim
bürger unten ankommt und nicht umgekehrt
abends macht alex musik für sich und für
mama merkel will man nicht mehr hier wo
es den menschen weniger gut geht als den
meisten anderen und ich frage mich wie
weit die kanzlerin selbst von diesem
teil der deutschen gesellschaft entrückt
ist 15 jahre im kanzleramt finanz euro
und flüchtlingskrise bewältigen warum
kommt sie nicht mal hierher zur familie
ist merkel zu lange kanzlerin nach den
tagen bei jessica alex und lea werde ich
das gefühl nicht mehr los dass
politikerinnen und politiker die zu
lange in ihrer welt lieben zu weit weg
sind vom echten leben ein leben das so
anders ist als jenes das im kanzleramt
spielt und ich sage ganz einfach
deutschland ist ein starkes land uns das
motiv in dem der an diese dinge
herangehen muss muss sein wir haben so
vieles geschafft wir schaffen das wir
schaffen das das ist ja der spruch der
quasi merkels haltung bei der
flüchtlingsfrage illustriert oder
darstellt der ist ja auch inzwischen
eigentlich legendäres zitat geworden
wir schaffen das
keinen anderen satz habe ich seit dem
sommer 2015 in deutschland öfter gehört
die einen zitieren ihn um merkel dafür
zu würdigen
andere um sich lustig zu machen über sie
und viele auch zynisch als sie wütend
sind über diesen ausspruch
nahe der tschechischen grenze über die
donau für die fahrt in die kreisstadt
deggendorf 120.000 einwohner
hier treten wir am 11 august 2015 bilder
in der polizeikaserne die zum ankommt
zentrum für flüchtlinge wurde das war
drei wochen vor merkels wir schaffen das
es war jener tag und die mir zum ersten
mal bewusst wurde was auf deutschland
zukommen wird
allein an diesem tag kamen hier 5000
menschen an vorwiegend aus syrien und
afghanistan darunter viele kinder
bilder die bedrückten und traurig
machten
das ankunfts zentrum von damals ist
heute wieder eine polizeikaserne
es ist ruhiger geworden deutlich wird
merkel mit ihrer aussage recht behalten
ein kilometer weiter steht jetzt ein amt
zentrum
hier warten 550 asylbewerber auf ihre
abschiebung
die bayerische fdp landesvorsitzende hat
mir diesen ort als treffpunkt angeboten
2015 august da kam so täglich bis zu
5000 m
die wurden ja hier ganz schnell dann in
busse gepackt und in ganz bayern und
deutschland verteidiger
natürlich sind diese zustände jetzt
nicht mehr aber die bevölkerung hat hier
wirklich zu leiden weil hier wirklich
einiges los ist in diesem
abschiebezentrum hier
hier gibt es viele randale ständig
polizeieinsätze auch die presse
berichtet darüber
es ist ein heißes pflaster und vor allem
auch die bürgerinnen und bürger die hier
wohnen die beschweren sich bei mir wenn
ich in deggendorf unterstände habt
kommen die her zu mir und erzählen mir
was hier so alles passiert also die
unsicherheit unter den frauen vor allem
ist groß gewordenen deggendorf ebner
steine war csu wählerin sie 2015 der
nationalkonservativen afd beigetreten
war zu beginn ihrer politischen laufbahn
stand die flüchtlingskrise
ebner steiner hat davon profitiert 2018
begleitete ich sie im bayrischen
wahlkampf bei der landtagswahl schoss
sie mit ihrer partei von null auf über
zehn prozent was merkel wenig später zum
rücktritt als cdu parteichefin bewog es
war ihm nach steiners größte erfolg der
sie zugleich isoliert hat der afg welt
verehrt sie werden nicht verachtet
sidler steiner steht für den graben der
sich tief durch die deutsche
gesellschaft sieht welche rolle spielt
merkel weiterentwicklung hier in
deutschland gesellschaftspolitischen den
letzten jahren gerade auch was sie
schaffen das wollen wir wirken schaffen
wenn ich mich zurückerinnern nach der
landtagswahl bayern kann hessen merkel
ist zurück getreten aber sie sind
eigentlich auch mitverantwortlich dass
sie als parteivorsitzende zurückgetreten
kann sein aber mehr fließen immer noch
das ist immer noch kanzlerin
viele prominente haben merkel damals
unterstützt flüchtlinge willkommen war
der slogan wir sind auf dem guten hoffen
bei peter maffay einmal im jahr öffnet
er hier die tore für ein bürgerfest für
mich oder für die kinder
der erfolgreiche deutsche sänger ließ
damals worten taten folgen er nahm
traumatisierte flüchtlingskinder auf
seinem gut auf versucht vorzustellen wie
sich jemand fühlt er irgendwo in eine
völlig andere welt hinein gerät in einer
anderen kulturkreis eine sprache weiter
faktisch wirklich bei null anfängt sind
dann ist jeder hilfestellung die an
solche mensch oder eine solche frau
wieder bekommen kann sinnvoll
maffay zeigt mir seien gut eine kirche
im neuen häuser stelle
er hat es vor jahren für sich erworben
sind sie stolz was ihr so nicht alles
geschafft
maffay war 13 als sein vater aus
rumänien nach deutschland floh eine
fluchtgeschichte seine flucht geschichte
die ihn prägte
2016 traf ich peter maffay in köln nach
einem konzert mit dem schweizer sänger
gelle
diskutierten über die kanzlerin und
maffay lobte merkels willkommenskultur
was wir an message haben ist zu einfach
freundschaft ist machbar über alle
grenzen hinweg inzwischen sind vier
jahre vergangen und die sicht der dinge
ist bei vielen eine andere geworden
sie haben sicher auch exponiert in der
flüchtlingskrise sie haben gesagt das
was merkel macht ist gut aber jetzt
haben sie so ein bisschen die meinung
revidiert oder sind sie immer noch der
meinung das ist ganz ganz im gegenteil
ich bin nach wie vor völlig davon
überzeugt dass ein land das viel zu
bieten hat und vieles auch im überfluss
besitzt davon etwas abgeben sollte wenn
man dann allerdings sieht wer alles auch
dieses system unter system unseren staat
unsere leistungsfähigkeit das in wolfen
der menschen hier missbraucht dann ist
das ein ansatzpunkt das schon
angela merkel wird 2021 spätestens
aufhören werden sie der kanzlerin nach
ich glaube nach vorn ist ja ein
überzogener begriff aber wir haben ja
noch nicht darüber gesprochen haben sie
mir die frage gestellt ist ist das was
sie gemacht hat richtig gut gewesen oder
nicht und wie wird man sich in
erinnerung behalten
und ich glaube ich habe geantwortet auch
wahrscheinlich besser als es manchmal
den anschein hat und das was sie getan
hat
das sehe ich auch wirklich so aus wie
man es sich daraus hat sie das einzig
richtige gemacht
ich glaube man würde ich tun wenn man
wenn man behauptet wurde sicherte an
schlechten tagen halten
[Musik]
drei fahrstunden weiter ostwärts liegt
bad kötzting im flüchtlingsheim der
bayerischen kleinstadt leben 30 nationen
zusammen in diesem ehemaligen
krankenhaus warten sie auf ihren
bescheid bleiben dürfen oder gehen
müssen
im januar 2016 berichtete ich über die
ehrenamtlichen helfer in den heimen in
bayern
tausende leisteten in den ersten monaten
der flüchtlingskrise am ausgabestellen
und im provisorischen schulzimmern
hilfsarbeiter in bad kötzting waren es
damals 60 freiwillige davon sind heute
noch 20 übrig geblieben
eine von ihnen brigitte ertl
sie koordiniert die freiwilligen helfer
ist gute seele helferin vertrauensperson
seit der ersten stunde für alle die hier
stranden
ich bin schon taufpatin geworden
bei taufen also essig wir haben
hochzeiten wir haben angeboten
wir haben alles was es sich nur
vorstellen also bei uns da sprüht alles
erleben ein leben im heim wo sie teils
schon seit beginn der flüchtlingskrise
auf ihren asyl entscheid warten viele
afrikaner weil syrer afghanen und iraker
priorität beurteilt worden
vor fünf jahren beobachtete ich behörden
und helfer in ganz deutschland die
völlig überfordert waren
heute ist es anders mehr als eine
million menschen sind gekommen
passt das zusammen wird das zukünftig in
deutschland passen schafft deutschland
das es geht hier nicht um das schaffen
wird das nicht aufhalten können
wir werden das müssen denke ich wir
kommen ja nicht raus aus dieser mühle ja
die leute kommen die leute werden
aufgenommen wenn sie das anschauen was
zurückgeschickt wird oder es steht in
keiner relation sie haben gesagt wir
müssen ja sind sie optimistisch dass das
wenn man muss dass es dann auch wenn man
wenn man zusammen hilft dann gehts ja
wenn man endlich aufhört mit diesen
negativen meinungen dann gehts dann
würde ich schon genau und wenn es muss
nicht jeder seine meinung komplett
ändern ein bisschen nur ein bisschen
menschlichkeit von jedem menschen und
dann geht
immer öfter bleiben zimmer im
flüchtlingsheim in bad kötzting leer
es kommen weniger noch 165000 stellten
2009 10 einen asylantrag in deutschland
rund eine million der flüchtlinge die
seit 2005 10 bis heute angekommen sind
werden in deutschland bleiben haben sie
noch eine gute meinung von der kanzlerin
ja doch als ich ich kann nicht sagen
dass die forderung merkels bloß weil
eben diese flüchtlingswelle oder so das
kann ich nicht sagen frau merkel hat war
eine eine gute kanzlerin nicht nicht
besser und nicht schlechter als alle
ihre vorgänger hat sie ihn zu viel
zugemutet vielleicht sie hat ihren
deutschen bürgern schon sehr viel
zugemutet hat ist muss ich schon sagen
zu viel manchmal auch schon so viel wenn
man die politische landschaft anschlag
merkel habe humanitär richtig gehandelt
höre ich immer wieder und ich teile
diese meinung aber hat merkel die zahl
der ankommenden unterschätzt und die
solidarität innerhalb der eu überschätzt
viele menschen zweifeln bis heute dass
sich afrikaner syrer afghanen im
organisierten wert bewussten und
ordnungsliebenden deutschland
integrieren können
diese zweifel haben die gesellschaft
gespalten und diese spaltung hat die
politlandschaft verändert
[Musik]
was lange unvorstellbar war in
deutschland ist in merkels kanzlerschaft
wirklichkeit geworden
eine patriotische nationalkonservative
partei konkurrenziert die großen
volksparteien die afg feiert wahlerfolg
um wahlerfolg es ist ein heißer
spätsommertag im jahr 2009 10 am ersten
september aber soll es frostig werden
für die regierungsparteien die afb will
erstmals stärkste kraft werden in einem
bundesland in brandenburg im februar
2016 besuchte ich eine wahlveranstaltung
der afg im osten ein paar dutzend
parteifreunde in einem kleinen
schützenhaus ich konnte mir damals nicht
vorstellen dass die erst 2014 gegründete
partei so schnell wachsen würde
ich bin auf dem weg nach werder an der
havel wo die alternative für deutschland
zum wahl fest lädt ein fest mit viel
polizei die zäune aufstellt gespaltene
gesellschaft gespalten es deutschland
seit dem aufschwung der afd
am ort genannt bismarckhöhe in vorfreude
parteimitglieder
unten an den zäunen bürgerinnen und
bürger mit ihren kindern welche die afg
nicht wollen
aufsicht distanz die afg jugend
dies ist für euch wenn ihr jetzt seht
wieder protestiert wird und dass euch
die leute als nazis wiederschein das ist
total nutzlos denn wenn sie sich die
protestanten wird die protest leute
ansehen das sind kleine kinder sind um
die zehn jahre alt die wissen gar nicht
was sie sagen und die werden aufs
übelste missbraucht das ist aber keine
echte gefahr für uns also ich sag mal
man hat der mann hatte die freie
meinungsäußerung und ich habe natürlich
kein problem wenn man auch gegen eine
partei sein kann weil ich meine das ist
ja auch das so das was demokratie
ausmacht
man muss nicht immer auf der gleichen
linie fahren also sollen die ruhig ihre
meinung kundtun
natürlich ist es immer so wenn man halt
selber einheit mit schimpfwörtern das
heißt was heißt schimpfwort aber mit
sage ich mal verbrechern denunziert es
ist das andere
ich selber fühle mich nicht für wir
nicht so ich mache dir machen hier
politik kurz vor 18 uhr computerhacker
der neue starke mann der afg weiter
rechts außen und damit vor allem im
osten erfolgreich
vorsichtiger optimismus ich glaube um 18
uhr die resultate
die afb wird zweitstärkste kraft im
bundesland knapp hinter merkels cdu und
deutlich vor allen anderen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele haben ja gesagt am ende des
wahlkampfes
sie hoffen sie freuen sich schon darauf
wenn es vorbei ist gar nichts ist vorbei
jetzt geht es erst richtig los geht das
[Applaus]
viele im saal träumen vom regieren
niemand will mit ihnen regieren in der
neue tricks in drei tage eine ewigkeit
wir spielen alle wie sich die politische
lage im land beschleunigt wie sie sich
dynamisiert keiner weiß was in ein oder
zwei jahren hier los ist und von daher
halten wir uns bereite machen uns
starten wir werden weiter kämpfen
welchen anteil hat die kanzlerin am
erfolg können die kanzlerin
die kanzlerin oder die ära merkel
getröte definitiv zu ende ihrer merkel
hat deutschland ausgezählt es gibt es
dafür einen relevanten politik für
erlaubt dass die eingangs politik ist
die euro rettungspolitik oder die
energiewende politik sind fundamentale
fehler gemacht vor die deutschland
schwer geschadet haben
die menschen spüren dass dunkle wolken
am horizont aufziehen sich sehr dunkle
wolken wo sie sagen ein weiter so wird
es nicht geben und insofern hat es
angela merkel und alle die die nachfolge
das sind ja alle parteien letztlich in
großen hauptbühne in der ab der politik
indirekt natürlich leider muss man so
alt
anteile von der afg die einst verlachte
splitterpartei fd ist volkspartei
überrascht bin ich heute nicht vor fünf
jahren hätte ich es aber nicht für
möglich gehalten
die flüchtlingskrise hatte afd den
entscheidenden auftrieb gegeben
hunderttausende unzufriedener aber auch
wertkonservativer in die arme getrieben
jene die so gar nichts mehr am hut haben
mit den regierenden mit merkel
[Musik]
in der früheren bundeshauptstadt bonn
treffe ich alexander mit er nimmt mich
mit zu einer veranstaltung der werte
union die er gegründet hat eine
innerparteiliche konservative gruppe
welche eine politikwende will in der cdu
die heißt ohne makel
ganz eilige leben dass es niemand für
die cdu sind
schlägt also was brauchen werden damit
einher geht eben diese kopflosigkeit dem
konservativen und wirtschaftsliberalen
über jahre hinweg die heimat match meint
damit grundsatzentscheidungen der
kanzlerin mit welchen sie in seinen
augen konservative prinzipien mit füßen
getreten habe die einführung der rente
mit 63 die abschaffung der allgemeinen
wehrpflicht den ausstieg aus der
kernenergie
ihre offene haltung zur
gleichgeschlechtlichen ehe und natürlich
ihre asylpolitik mit hat in bonn eine
veranstaltung organisiert zum thema aus
den fehlern der asylpolitik lernen
geladen hatte hans georg maßen den
früheren verfassungsschutzpräsidenten
der wegen kritik an merkels
flüchtlingspolitik zurücktreten musste
das massen kommt passt nicht allen
die briten haben sich schon hinbekommen
spart
ja ich meine es ist ja in ordnung wenn
jemand der meinung ist dass refugees
welcome sind das kann man ja politisch
vertreten was nicht in ordnung ist aus
meiner sicht ist die beleidigung an
herrn maßen
das überschreitet aus meiner sicht das
vernünftige maß einer politischen
auseinandersetzung
als sie diese einwanderungspolitik
glaube ich hat zu einer radikalisierung
der politik in deutschland geführt
ein junges mitglied der werte union
entfernt das plakat
jamann
im winter 2018 begleitet dich alexander
mitch zu einer gründungsversammlung der
werte union in baden württemberg damals
kam ein gutes dutzend leute welche
innerhalb der cdu merkels kurs infrage
stellten
heute zählt mix werte union fast 4000
mitglieder schon andere eindruck als
werde größer absolut ja da haben wir
merken dass wir auf der richtigen welle
sind und dass die menschen unsere
überzeugung teilen und die menschen
kommen heute in scharen um maßen zu
hören
der stellt so ziemlich alles in frage
die deutschland die die regierung wie
merkel in der flüchtlings und
asylpolitik agiert die frage ist ist die
fehlgeleitete asylpolitik korrigierbar
ich bin der meinung sie ist olbia ich
glaube die mutter aller probleme ist der
fehlende politische wille realitäten zu
erkennen
probleme zu erkennen und diese probleme
dann lösen zu wollen
von daher bin ich zuversichtlich dass
wir als werte union die gewinner der
geschichte sein werden
herr mit schon herr maßen zufrieden wie
es heute gelaufen ist so hervorragend
sie haben gemerkt die leute waren
begeistert wir haben vielen aus der
seele gesprochen
genau so machen wir weiter und wenn sie
in zwei jahren wieder kommen dann sind
wir wahrscheinlich drei mal so viele hat
die kanzlerin sie ein bisschen in die
politik getrieben
ich war eigentlich immer ein politisch
denkender mensch gewesen auch im
vergangenen jahr als ich aufgehört habe
verfassungsschutzpräsident habe ich von
politisch gedacht aber jetzt habe ich
eine gewisse freiheit dass ich ebenfalls
auch politisch wirken kann und deswegen
wird es dann besser an frau merkel weg
sein wird es wird anders werden aber ich
hoffe dass wir zu einer politik wende
kommen als ein dankeschön maßen und
mitch wollen nicht mehr mit merkel als
sie ihnen zu weit nach links gerückt ist
beim weggehen erzählt mir maßen dass er
gerne in die schweiz komme
dort könne er sehr offen mit bürgern und
politikern über migration reden
innerparteiliche akteure wie er button
weiter daran arbeiten hackls ende
vorzeitig herbeizuführen
im juni 2011 hat die kanzlerin eine
entscheidung getroffen die stark zur
entfremdung zwischen merkel und den
wertkonservativen in der cdu beigetragen
hat merkel die physikerin hat nach dem
reaktorunglück in fukushima den
atomausstieg beschlossen und damit die
energiewende
[Musik]
fukushima hat meine haltung zur
kernenergie verändert
seit hier sind allein im nordosten
deutschlands tausende windparks
entstanden ganz viele davon hat custom
porn geplant und gebaut
mindestens 180 ein understatement in
wirklichkeit sind es vielmehr 2016
besuchte ich komm schon einmal die
produktion lief auf hochtouren
er und seine leute bauten und bauten und
bauten
heute steht die produktion still
vorübergehend nun ja sie haben zum einen
langen planungszeiten für
windenergieprojekte das heißt sie haben
vorlaufzeiten von mindestens 3
realistisch bis zu fünf jahren für ein
windenergieprojekt und zurzeit haben wir
halt sehen wir eine überbürokratisierung
des genehmigungsverfahrens und dadurch
natürlich sehr schleppend anlaufende
genehmigung die deutsche bürokratie
bremst den bauboom aus nicht aber
windradbauer porn
er plant und produziert auch in
frankreich und in schweden
deutsche windradbauer sind zu vorreitern
in europa geworden auch weil merkel die
bedeutung von klima und nachhaltigkeit
in der politik für kant hat als andere
hornig mit zu einer seine anlagen
genauer auf eine seiner anlagen 137
meter hoch mit blick auf seine windparks
[Musik]
heute in die landschaft google richtig
schön klare sicht haben 2022 soll das
letzte akw vom netz
in zeiten in denen deutschland immer
mehr strom braucht klappt das was wir
schon alles geschafft haben dann wäre es
aus meiner sicht in deutschland würde
man sagen man sagen wir lassen jetzt
nicht in der haut stecken
warum sollten halbe strecke aufgeben es
ist diese überzeugung die ich in diesem
land immer wieder mit bekomme dennoch
habe ich zweifel dass der schnelle
atomausstieg die richtige entscheidung
merkels war
deutschland ist zwar pionier bei den
erneuerbaren
der entscheid hat aber auch merkels
partei- weiter entzweit und viele
befürchten dass dem land bald der eigene
strom ausgehen wird
denn auch in der lausitz soll bald
einmal schluss sein
hier mit der kohle ich bin auf dem weg
zum tagebau schwarze pumpe 2014 besuchte
ich das dorf profis stand kurz davor weg
zu kommen damit man die kohle unter dem
dorf abbauen kann
400 familien sollten umgesiedelt werden
die regierung wollte wieder vermehrt auf
kohle setzen nach dem beschlossenen
atomausstieg jetzt ist wieder alles
anders
dafür soll nun der tagebau weg jenes
feld und jene weiten wo die menschen in
der lausitz wie dieter freisler seit
jahrzehnten kohle abbauen für energie im
ganzen land was bedeuten die kohl ist
für die region hier für die lausitzer
die war ja über generation arbeitgeber
da haben wir die generation ihr geld
verdient wenn das ende ist es ändern
abgebauten kohle erde weiter als das
auge reicht
ein realer anblick über ein feld das
spätestens 2038 stillgelegt sein soll
oder früher
denn die kohlegegner von ende gelände
fordern ende mit schwarze pumpe und zwar
sofort weil durch kohle energie zu viel
co2 ausgestoßen werde in den umliegenden
dörfern versammeln sich die bewohner am
selben abend zu mahnwachen für die kohle
für die schwarze pumpe für ihre existenz
die sie nicht hergeben wollen in der
lausitz ihr vereinslokal hatten die
aktiven kumpels und die in rente
natürlich mit kohle die cats vom tagebau
einmal im monat treffen sie sich die
kohle niederzumachen abzuschalten 38 ist
falsch wir müssen eben nicht wie es mit
mitarbeit hier weitergeht in der region
in den dörfern sind immer weniger
energie werden 500 menschen im dorf das
haben wir zurzeit wie 465 265 aus den
worten der kumpels hörig zukunftsangst
und verunsicherung und merkel ist für
sie jene die ihnen die zukunft nimmt von
wir halten wir gar nicht mehr nur die
liebe auch bundeskanzlerin
das waren allein entscheidung ohne not
muss man ohne not muss man ja mal sagen
ja
[Musik]
sich schon an wie die flüchtlingsfrage
spaltet auch die energiewende das land
und die gesellschaft
merkel hat diesen entscheid nach dem
unglück in fukushima beschlossen
emotional geleitet die in der
flüchtlingskrise beide entscheidungen
hat sie nicht kalkuliert und berechnet
wie sonst so alles in ihren kanzler
jahren
beide entscheidungen haben tiefe gräben
aufgerissen in der deutschen
gesellschaft
[Musik]
und dann ist da noch die spd merkels
koalitionspartnerin seit 2014 im
sinkflug
während merkel die cdu 18 jahre lang als
parteichefin fast unumstritten führte
hat die spd zehn mal den vorsitzenden
ausgewechselt und ist von 35 auf 14
prozent wähleranteile abgestürzt
ich bin in brieselang in brandenburg bei
genossen die der spd treu sind
gründerväter der partei im osten nach
der wende die sich heute regelmäßig im
wintergarten von norbert utah schenke
treffen dem vorsteher des spd
ortsvereins 2017 nach der bundestagswahl
besuchte ich sie schon einmal als es
darum ging ob die spd nochmals in einer
regierung treten soll
zusammen mit merkel in die große
koalition schon damals waren sie
skeptisch
zwei jahre später sitzen sie wieder hier
ihre partei regiert immer noch mit
merkels union und ist noch weiter
abgestürzt
wo sind wir anders
mir fehlt eine führungspersönlichkeit
die märkte ist nur unglaublich starke
frau hat die spd nicht merkel hat die
cdu sozialdemokratisiert muss sagen
viele die nach nach links nach rechts zu
setzen und und erntet als größere als
also als regierung als eigentliche
regierung als bundeskanzlerin das was
die spd zustande gebracht das ist
eigentlich das irre und das betrifft
natürlich viele genossen hoch die sagen
also wofür stand wenn wir uns ab wir
strampeln uns ab und sie spart sich hin
und ich bin die größe
guido speer zog die reißleine
im letzten sommer schreiber auf facebook
dass er seine spd ämter niederlegen
er habe keine lust mehr ein totes pferd
zu reiten
zwei monate später treffe ich ihn wieder
in berlin die genossen halten parteitag
und speer will zurück zu seiner alten
liebe
also ich bin nicht so der freund von
slogan so verwundert hier die rolltreppe
ins glück schauen wir mal was könnte das
sein
in tucson ja zumindest die rolltreppe in
eine bessere zukunft hofft man zumindest
hofft man andererseits schlechter kann
es ja auch nicht mehr wehren
noch schlechter wäre 5 prozent dass man
auch besorgt
naja besorgt insgesamt wieder weg
weitergeht
jetzt sind sie zu hause jetzt bin ich
zuhause zu hause das ist noch ein lied
ist liebe liebe meine frau meine kinder
aber ansonsten deshalb ist ein gewisser
art von heimat die ich mir selber
gesucht habe seit 89 kinder freiwillig
da rein und dann rein erzählte herz die
spd wählt eine neue parteiführung wieder
diesmal eine doppelspitze
norbert walter borjans und saskia esken
die einen neuen kurs weiter nach links
weg von merkels mitte eine neue zeit
versprechen wieder hört die signale die
neue zeit sie ruft
es geht denn die spd ja ich glaube nicht
dass hier die regierung stellen wir also
gegen den kanzler stellen werden aber
wir werden glaube ich weiterhin
hoffentlich mit einer region sein und
auch eine wichtige rolle spielen darum
konstant
die spd leidet sucht ihren weg neben
merkel ist die spd wirklich opfer von
merkels pragmatischen kurs oder nur teil
der krise der europäischen
sozialdemokratie oder fehlt die einfach
eine leaderfigur es ist wohl von allem
etwas was die spd zu dem gemacht hat was
sie heute ist eine 14 prozent partei in
der hoffnung auf eine neue zeit in der
es besser wird wenn merkel einmal weg
sein wird
merkel weg im herbst 2000 21 will sie
aus dem kanzleramt ausziehen
irgendwie unvorstellbar wer soll er nach
folgen
ich fahre zur cdu parteichefin annegret
kramp karrenbauer in die machtzentrale
der cdu ins konrad adenauer haus wo sie
uns zum gespräch lädt was ich an diesem
abend noch nicht weiß zwei wochen später
wird sie ankündigen dass sie als
kanzlerkandidatin nicht zur verfügung
stehe
hier haben sie sonst die vorstandsitzung
hier sind die fans werden und die
vorstandsvorsitzenden immer also wo
jetzt das mikrofon steht sitzt in der
regel die kanzlerinnen ich dann eher
2017 traf ich sie im saarland damals war
sie dort ministerpräsidentin im
wahlkampf für merkel
sie ist eine vertraute der kanzlerin
merkel machte sie zur generalsekretärin
und zur parteichefin eine von merkels
gnaden die nun die cdu führt eine partei
die 2014 noch 41 wähler prozent hatte
jetzt 27 der viele den rücken gekehrt
haben vor allem struktur und
wertkonservative hat angela merkel ihre
partei zu weit nach links gezogen
gesellschaftspolitisch
wirtschaftspolitisch ich kann mit diesen
kategorien rechts und links wenig
anfangen was angela merkel in all den
jahren geschafft hat war dass sie die
partei immer auch ein stück weit auf die
höhe der gesellschaftlichen
veränderungen mitgebracht hat dann ist
es einfach so die realität verändert
sich und eine partei die mehrheitsfähig
in der mitte sein will
die musste ich mit dieser realität
auseinandersetzen und muss eben
antworten geben die die menschen im jahr
2020 überzeugt und nicht diejenigen die
etwa 1950 die cdu toll gefunden haben
das ist immer eine herausforderung und
an dieser herausforderung hat jeder
vorsitzende hat jede vorsitzenden zu
arbeiten und ich tue das auch frau
merkel hat sich gefreut als sie
nachfolgerin wurden als
parteivorsitzende sie würde sich auch
freuen wenn sie kanzlerin werden
das müssen sie frau merkel fragen
möchten sie ich möchte als
parteivorsitzende dafür sorgen dass die
cdu so stark abschneiden bei der
bundestagswahl dass wir dann die
kanzlerin oder den kanzler wieder
stellen aber die logische kandidatin ist
die parteivorsitzende sie die
parteivorsitzende führt diesen prozess
von vorne das habe ich immer gesagt und
wir werden am ende dieses jahres auf dem
parteitag die entscheidung treffen
die aktualität hat uns bei den
dreharbeiten überhaupt nach dem
wahlfiasko in thüringen wird sie nicht
mehr kanzlerin und merkels abgang könnte
früher kommen als angekündigt
wann immer das sein wird merkels
vermächtnis ist ein land das
wirtschaftlich glänzend dasteht indem
aber zu viele menschen zu tiefen löhnen
arbeiten müssen und deren kinder in
armut leben
michaels vermächtnis ist auch ein land
in dem sich die parteienlandschaft
grundlegend verändert hat in der die
beiden staatstragenden volksparteien von
einst nicht mehr zwingend den anspruch
geltend machen können den kanzler oder
die kanzlerin zu stellen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
merkels vermächtnis ist auch die afd
die neben der einst alternativlosen
kanzlerin rasant eine alternative werden
konnte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
merkels vermächtnis ist aber auch in
deutschland das wirtschaftlich und
politisch ein tragender grundpfeiler
geworden ist für europa humanitär hat
sie maßstäbe gesetzt und sie hat sorge
getragen zu deutschland und zu europa
mit ihrem unvergleichlich pragmatischen
regierungsstil nach 15 jahren an der
macht hat angela merkel in ihrem land
noch immer zustimmungswerte von nahezu
70 prozent
auch das ist ein vermächtnis
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von dr
genießen sie cremige rezepte mit der
camembert cremiger genuss seit 1902